pensemos un poco en la noción de tamaño
atómico o radio atómico
en este vídeo el primero pensarás que
esto es algo bastante directo si estoy
intentando calcular el radio de algún
tipo de objeto circular sólo pienso en
cuál es la distancia entre el centro de
ese objeto circular y la orilla de ella
la longitud de esta línea será el radio
y entonces muchas personas cuando
conceptualizan un átomo imaginan un
núcleo positivo con los protones en el
centro e imaginan los electrones en
orbitales fijos alrededor de ese núcleo
podrían imaginar algunos electrones en
este orbital de aquí solo orbitando
alrededor o podría haber algunos más
en este orbital de afuera orbitando
alrededor orbitando alrededor aquí y
podrías decir que es fácil calcular el
radio atómico solo obtengo la distancia
entre el núcleo y el electrón más
alejado y podríamos llamar a eso radio
y eso podría funcionar excepto por el
hecho de que esa no es la manera
correcta de conceptualizar cómo los
electrones se mueven como están
distribuidos alrededor del núcleo los
electrones no están en órbitas de la
misma manera en la que los planetas
están alrededor del sol hemos hablado de
esto en vídeos anteriores
están en orbitales los cuales son
realmente distribuciones de probabilidad
de donde podrían estar los electrones
pero no están muy bien definidos
podrías tener un orbital y solo te lo
muestro en dos dimensiones pero de hecho
debería de estar en tres dimensiones o
tal vez hay una gran probabilidad de que
los electrones estén donde estoy
dibujando en este verde más sombreado
pero hay algo de probabilidad de que los
electrones estén en esta área de aquí y
algo de probabilidad de que los
digamos que hay incluso una menor
probabilidad de que los electrones estén
de esta manera
aquí
podrías decir que en este momento el
electrón está ahí el electrón más
alejado y podrías decir está bien este
es el radio pero en el siguiente momento
hay algo de probabilidad es mucho más
probable que acabe aquí pero hay algo de
probabilidad de que vaya a estar ahí
y entonces el radio podría estar ahí y
entonces estos electrones estos
orbitales estas distribuciones de
probabilidad difusas no tienen una
orilla definida por lo que como podrías
decir cuál es el radio de un átomo
realmente y hay varias técnicas para
pensar en eso una de las técnicas para
pensar en esto es decir digamos que
tengo dos del mismo átomo que son dos
átomos del mismo elemento que no están
conectados entre sí que no están
enlazados entre sí que no son parte de
la misma molécula y eres capaz de
determinar de alguna manera lo más cerca
que los puedes poner uno del otro sin
que se enlacen
dirías que es lo más cerca que pueden
estar uno del otro
digamos que ese es uno y luego por aquí
está el otro y si pudiera saber esa
distancia la distancia mínima sin
realmente ya sabes hay una fuerte
influencia sucediendo aquí pero la
distancia mínima que podrías ver entre
estas dos y luego podrías tomar la mitad
de ella
esa es una noción y es de hecho llamado
el radio de van der vaart otra manera es
decir qué pasa si tienes dos átomos del
mismo elemento que están unidos uno con
el otro
están unidos el uno con el otro a través
de un enlace covalente un enlace
covalente hemos visto esto en el pasado
un enlace covalente esencialmente tiene
dos átomos este es el núcleo de uno este
es el núcleo del otro y están
compartiendo electrones sus nubes de
electrones sus nubes de electrones de
hecho se traslapan unas con otras
de hecho se traslapan unas con otras por
lo que en un enlace covalente los
electrones en ese enlace pueden pasar
algo de su tiempo en este átomo y algo
de su tiempo en este átomo de aquí y
entonces cuando tienes un enlace
covalente como este puedes entonces
encontrar la distancia entre los dos
núcleos y tomar la mitad de ella y
llamarla llamar la radio atómico
todas estas son diferentes maneras de
pensar en esto dejando eso claro
pensemos en cómo serían las tendencias
para tamaño atómico o radio atómico en
la tabla periódica la primera cosa en la
que debemos pensar es cuál crees que
sería la tendencia para radio atómico
mientras nos movemos mientras nos
movemos a lo largo de un periodo digamos
que estamos en el cuarto periodo e
iremos del potasio al crypton cuál crees
que será la tendencia aquí y si quieres
pensar en los extremos cómo crees que se
compara el potasio al crypton en
términos de radio atómico te invito a
que pausa el vídeo y pienses en eso tú
solo bien cuando estás en el cuarto
periodo los electrones más alejados
estarán en tu cuarto orbital
aquí estás llenando 4s 14 s 2 luego
comienzas a llenar el sub orbital
y luego comienzas a llenar otra vez en 4
p 14 y así sucesivamente comienzas a
llenar el suborbital p mientras vas del
potasio al crypton llenas el cuarto
orbital más alejado qué es lo que pasa
ahí cuando estás en el potasio tienes 19
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 7
1819 protones y tienes 19 electrones los
dibujaré de esta manera 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 x 16 7 18 pero solo
tienes un electrón en el más alejado en
el cuarto orbital solo digamos que hay
es donde es electrón está por el momento
solo para visualizarlo no tiene que
estar ahí necesariamente pero ayuda a
visualizarlo este electrón de ahí tiene
19 protones tienes algunas fuerzas de
coulón que lo están atrayendo que lo
mantienen ahí
pero si vas al crypton sólo diré que
tendrás una carga positiva mucho mayor
en el núcleo tienes 1 2 3 4 5 6
tienes 36 tienes una carga positiva de
36 déjame escribir eso más 36 aquí
tienes más 19 y tienes 36 electrones 36
electrones ya perdí la cuenta pero en el
orbital más alejado en el cuarto tendrás
el 12 ese y luego tendrás el 6 p por lo
que tendrás 8 en tu orbital más alejado
serían 12
4 5 6 7 8 una manera de pensar en eso es
tienes una carga positiva mayor en el
centro y tienes una carga negativa mayor
en ese orbital alejado lo que llevará al
orbital más alejado hacia adentro
tendrá más
podrías imaginarlo en una manera ya
sabes tendrá más atracción de coulón hay
y debido a eso ese orbital de afuera se
acercará al núcleo -el crypton será más
pequeño tendrá un radio atómico menor
que el potasio y entonces la tendencia
cuando vas a la derecha es que estás
obteniendo la tendencia general diría
que te estás haciendo más
p
yo
mientras vas a la derecha en un periodo
y esa es la razón por la cual el
elemento con el átomo más pequeño no es
hidrógeno es helio el helio es de hecho
menor que el hidrógeno dependiendo de
cuál técnica utilizas para medirlo y eso
es porque si tomamos el caso más simple
en el hidrógeno tienes un protón tienes
un protón en el núcleo y luego tienes un
electrón en ese orbital 1s y en el helio
tienes 22 protones en el núcleo y no
dibujaré los neutrones
obviamente hay diferentes isótopos
diferentes números de neutrones pero
ahora tienes 2 electrones en tu orbital
más alejado y entonces tienes más creo
podrías decir
podrías decir que tienes una mayor
atracción de coloma aquí esto es más
y luego estos dos combinados son menos
dos serán atraídos hacia el núcleo esa
es la tendencia mientras vamos a la
derecha mientras vamos de la izquierda a
la derecha de la tabla periódica nos
hacemos más pequeños y qué crees que
pasaría mientras vamos hacia abajo en la
tabla periódica mientras vamos hacia
abajo en la tabla periódica en un grupo
determinado bien mientras vamos hacia
abajo en un grupo por cada nuevo
elemento abajo en el grupo estamos en un
nuevo periodo estamos agregando un
orbital nuevo agregamos más y más
orbitales aquí solo tienes el primer
orbital luego el segundo orbital y cada
orbital se aleja cada vez más cuando vas
hacia abajo en la tabla periódica te
estás haciendo más
gran d
tienes un radio atómico mayor
dependiendo de cómo lo estás metiendo
así que cuál es la tendencia general si
te haces más grande yendo hacia abajo
eso significa que te haces más pequeño
al ir hacia arriba te haces
más
genio
de que yo mientras vas hacia arriba
entonces cuál será el más pequeño ya
dijimos que el helio era el más pequeño
así que cuáles serían unos de los más
grandes cuáles serían los átomos más
grandes serían los átomos aquí abajo
abajo en la izquierda
estos serán grandes y estos pequeños
grandes
aquí
d
qué
news
acá y la tendencia general es que
mientras vas de la parte de abajo en la
izquierda a la parte de arriba en la
derecha te haces más
p
yo